Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm very excited to introduce
our next keynote
speaker, Joe Cheng,
the CTO of RStudio.
And since Joe is
talking about Shiny,
I thought I'd introduce
him with a little story,
a personal story, about Shiny.
And as many of you know, I
wrote the book Mastering Shiny,
and you might think,
well, why did Hadley
write that and not Joe?
So Joe came to me, I don't know,
like four or five years ago
and said, "Hey, like, I want
to write a book about Shiny.
What should I do?"
And so I gave him my book
writing advice, which is
writing a book is really easy.
All you need to do is write
for an hour a day for a year,
and at the end of the year
you'll have that book.
Now, as far as I know,
no one has successfully
followed that advice.
So it's provably
terrible advice.
And after my advice failed
for Joe for some time,
I kind of took pity on
him and said, "Oh, hey, I
love writing books,
I'll write it for you."
And it kind of cut to
the end of the story.
I wrote mastering Shiny,
and to say thank you,
Joe built me a bike, which
is the most amazing bicycle
that I've ever
ridden in my life.
And it seemed to me just
like this perfect example
of a win-win.
Like, I got all of the
pleasure of writing a book
and I didn't have to
build a bicycle myself.
And Joe got all the pleasure
of building me a bike
and didn't have to write a book.
So please welcome Joe Cheng.
Thank you so much,
Hadley. Well, that's
less funny after he
told that beautiful story about
the bike, I feel kind of bad now.
July 31, 2012.
Was the day that we first
showed Shiny to the world.
We were at JSM, not
even a scheduled talk.
Bryan Lewis just lent us 10
minutes at the end of his talk
and we showed Shiny.
And if you consider
that date, July 31st,
to be the birth of
Shiny, then this
is a particularly special talk
for me to give to you today.
Because that means that
Shiny is 10 years old.
10 years, it's hard to believe.
So to mark this
anniversary, I thought
I'd do things a little bit
different, this time, than usual.
I usually focus on what's
coming, what's new,
and I wanted to take
this opportunity
to talk a little
bit about how Shiny
started and the story of
how Shiny started really
begins with Danny Kaplan.
Oh! Yeah,
some Danny fans in the audience.
Danny and his students
at Macalester College
were the very first
beta testers of RStudio IDE.
This is going way better
than I thought it would.
And Danny's feedback
was so great.
His fingerprints are all
over the IDE even to this day.
You can see all
the parts that he
influenced with his feedback.
And in early 2011,
Danny asked JJ for a way
to build interactive
apps in R that he
could use to demonstrate
statistical and calculus
concepts.
And JJ being JJ, in about a week,
he built this.
This is the manipulate
feature in RStudio.
Sort of the proto
Shiny, if you will.
And manipulate is great because it almost
couldn't be simpler.
This is how manipulate works.
You give it some kind of
plot generating function or
plot generating expression.
And include one or
more unbound variables
that you want the user to
be able to control, then
for each of those.
You describe how you
want that to appear.
So there are a couple of, there's slider,
and there is lookup, a
couple of things like that.
And this worked great
and Danny ran with it
and created quite a few
really beautifully thought
out and assembled
tiny applets that
illustrated these concepts.
And he bundled them together
as part of this project mosaic.
Now it wasn't long, as tends
to happen with software;
it wasn't long before
some questions started.
Boy, it sure would be nice to
have a customizable layout.
Can I have those inputs?
Show up in two
columns, for example.
Could I have more input types?
Maybe multiple outputs at once
instead of just one plot, maybe
different kinds of
outputs, like tables,
and maybe instead of
just showing things,
we could also take some actions
when the user clicked a button
or something like that.
And finally...
Why do people have
to be using RStudio
IDE to use these applets?
It would be great
to be able to take
these little interactive
things and move them out.
All of those totally
reasonable, totally reasonable,
great suggestions.
And what he was describing was
a full interactive UI framework.
Now, that was something
that JJ and I clearly
had the technical
ability to create.
But I felt really strongly,
this is not something
that we should do.
This felt like a trap to me.
Because UI programming sucks.
This is how I
honestly felt in 2012.
I had spent a lot of my
career writing complex UIs.
And the reason it sucks is
because of this idiom called
event handlers.
This is the way all UI
worked in those days.
The way way event
handlers work is so simple,
I can explain it
to you right now.
The idea is this when x
happens, do y. In this example
x being that some
text box has changed.
And in response we
want to do y, which
is update the text of this
status label to some new value.
Very, very simple.
The problem is when you have
multiple of these in your UI,
they become hard
to reason about.
Similar to global variables.
If you've ever been
warmed off of programming
with extensive use
of global variables,
it's the reasoning
that becomes hard.
And this is a huge problem
because as your UI gets
more complex and the
logic gets more complex,
it starts requiring extremely
high levels of skill
and discipline to do well.
It can be done, clearly
we've had complex
UIs for a long time,
but it really is
deceptively difficult
and takes the most disciplined
and talented engineers.
And if you don't
get it quite right,
if you don't have that level
of skill and discipline,
you end up with bugs and
not just normal bugs,
like freezing and errors,
but more pernicious ones,
like an app confidently giving
you an answer that's incorrect.
And that's bad enough
in a normal piece
of consumer software
but to inflict that
onto the R community?
To put the tools into their
hands to confidently get
the wrong answer.
It was unconscionable.
So we didn't do it.
And the problem was, as much
as I hated event handlers,
I couldn't come up with not
only a better alternative,
but any alternative.
I had been doing this kind
of programming day and day
out for years,
constantly thinking
there must be a
better way than this.
And I could not even
conceive of a better way.
Until around May...
May 2012.
Sorry, there's a lot
of dates in this talk.
In may of 2012, I watched a
screencast for a brand new web
framework called Meteor.
And this was the craziest
thing I'd ever seen.
It blew me away.
There were so many
ideas in Meteor
that they were demonstrating
in their code that
felt like alien technology
to me, or like a magic trick.
One particular magic
trick among many
just stuck itself in my brain
and I couldn't dislodge it.
And it was this.
Like any other web
framework, Meteor
had a way for you
to have templates.
You would write some HTML
markup, and in the middle,
you would throw in some
dynamic value like a name.
And this is where in a
traditional web framework,
you would then attach
an event handler
to make sure that
template was re-rendered
at the appropriate time.
But the media guy
said this, verbatim"
"I changed the data and
the template updates.
There's no event handlers.
It just works."
And he said it like that.
And I was like,
There's no event handlers?
It just works?
What?
Like...
How?
How does that just work?
And that was me.
I mean, for like days
and maybe a week or two
after, I couldn't
shake this thought.
How do they do that?
And the only thing
I could think of
is maybe they just
re-execute everything.
Every time something
changes, they just
re-execute all of
their templates.
But that didn't seem to be
what they were talking about.
Finally, I couldn't
take it anymore.
I just went and googled.
How does Meteor work?
Don't worry, you're
not supposed to be
able to see the code here.
But there was Stack Overflow answer
that pointed to this file
and said, this is how it works.
And I just include
the screenshot
so that you can see
how short it is.
71 lines of code.
With pretty copious comments.
So I downloaded the
Meteor repo onto my laptop
and got on a plane ride
home from a conference.
And I told myself by the
time I get off this plane,
I'm going to understand
how this works.
And I did.
It's actually pretty
straightforward once you know the trick.
It's simple, it's elegant.
And it felt to me like, maybe
these guys are onto something.
This is actually the
better way to do this.
Not just a trick, but a
genuinely new way to do things.
And I was very
impressed, loved it.
It was super satisfying to
find out how it worked.
And then I close my
laptop and I don't know,
watched a movie or something.
No dots were connected that day.
Shiny was not born that day.
In fact, it was
almost a month later.
When it finally
hit me, and the way
it hit me was a little weird.
I swear
this is true.
This has never
happened to me before since.
That morning
I woke up, I opened
my eyes and the very first
conscious thought in my head
was an entire web framework.
Yeah that's not a joke.
That literally is what happened.
And I will show you literally
what it looked like.
It started with a
simple HTML interface.
The most important
thing was you weren't
going to have to write any
JavaScript as an app developer.
All you had to do
is write HTML tags
and include IDs and
classes that would
indicate where inputs
and outputs were
and what they were called.
And we would power that
with reactive server logic
using that trick from Meteor.
All you'd have to
do is explain how
an output is to be created based
on these input values and Shiny
would take care of
knowing when to...
You guys know how it works.
And then a WebSocket connection
to tie them both together.
And this what I'm showing,
that was the first
thought in my brain
when I woke up that morning.
It felt like a gift.
But the weirdest thing
about that morning,
wasn't necessarily the
completeness of this vision.
It was the timing.
This is, this is terrifying.
I've never told this
story in public,
but I thought it was
a thing that I really
wanted to share with you now.
That day, June 15th,
2012, was supposed
to be my last day at RStudio.
That spring I was just feeling
Like my... Boy, this is terrifying...
That spring, I was feeling
like my career had plateaued.
I was a software engineer
in my mid-thirties.
I loved the work that JJ
and I were doing together,
but it was just the two of us.
And all around I looked at
my classmates and people
that I had been peers
with at past companies,
and I saw them starting
companies and riding rocket
ships, you know, up
the corporate ranks
at the biggest tech
companies and just
doing the most amazing things
that I would read about
in the news.
And I was deathly afraid
of being left behind
and I felt like in order for
me to feel like I was a success,
I was going to need to
start my own company.
So I went to JJ.
I mean, I've been with
JJ for a long time,
and I opened up to him
about how I was feeling,
and he said to me, "I
totally understand,
and if that's what you want
to do, I will support you.
I'll help you however I can."
But this was in
the run up to UseR,
we were trying to get R
Markdown off the ground.
He had a keynote.
So my commitment to
him was, I'm going
to fully focus on RStudio.
Until UseR is over.
And as soon as UseR is
over, I'm going to go on leave
and think about my future.
And if all went well, I'd never
come back from that leave.
The last day of UseR,
June 15, 2012,
it was that day.
It was that day is my point.
What was supposed to be
my last day at RStudio.
And in the blink of an eye.
When this appeared in my brain.
It was a light
switch was flipped
and all those feelings I had
all the fear and insecurity.
Were just erased in an instant.
And I was completely
consumed by this curiosity
of would this work?
Can we build this?
And just filled with this
creative drive to see this
happen.
And I tell the story because
I want you to understand.
How profound a gift,
really, this was the first of
many profound gifts
that Shiny gave to me.
I was about to make a pretty
big life and career decision.
That I think would
have been a mistake
because I was making it out
of fear and out of insecurity.
And what Shiny gave
me was something
to run towards, with
curiosity, with creativity,
and it's just been such
a magical 10 years.
I wouldn't trade
it for anything.
Oh, my gosh.
OK now, I took this sketch,
you know, jotted it down
and ran down to find JJ,
you know, we were at UseR
and I showed him I was
like, look at this.
And he immediately got it.
I mean, instantly he
was like, "This is it.
This is what you work on.
From now on, forget
everything else
that you're working on this."
And he just
requested one change.
It took him some
time to convince me.
He said, why are we
making people write HTML?
And I was like, I'm saving
them from JavaScript.
They can learn HTML.
But he was pretty insistent
and he was very right.
And what we ended
up was this writing
R on both the
client and the server.
Of course, you can use
HTML if you want to, but,
this is pretty much what
we have today in Shiny.
So with this idea in hand, we
spent a frantic seven weeks,
making Shiny into
a proof of concept
that we could present at JSM.
And seven weeks later,
this is what we had.
This is the demo that
we displayed at JSM
and we had settled on a
tagline that was "Easily
create interactive web
applications in R,
without needing to know
HTML, JavaScript and CSS."
So now we knew that
it was possible.
But now what?
Now to me,
my ambitions for
this was, gee, I
hope someone uses
this and likes it.
And JJ, being JJ said,
"Why shouldn't all R users
be making apps and
why shouldn't Shiny
be the way that they make them?"
So the three of us got to work.
Winston Chang joined the
company just a very short time
after JSM, and we got to
work, working on Shiny.
And in order for
Shiny to be a success,
for it to have an impact
on the R community,
there were three big questions
that we had to answer,
and the answers had to
be yes, across the board.
The first question, can
we even build this in R?
We did the proof of concept.
Can we take it to production?
Because the
conventional wisdom was
that R is a language for
stats, not web frameworks.
Secondly, are R users
ready to write web apps?
Because writing web apps is very
different than data analysis.
There are different
muscles that you need
to use and Shiny in particular,
was going to ask people to
learn concepts that nobody,
almost nobody had seen before.
Were R users ready to do that?
And the third was would
the R community respond?
In 2012,
I mean, if you
weren't there, it
might be a little bit
hard to picture, but...
We were nobodies,
we were unknowns.
And not only that, RStudio, it was almost a little
suspicious what we were doing.
Here's this, like,
weirdly, fully formed IDE
that they don't charge for.
There's no pro version.
They're working on it full-time.
So people were wondering,
what's the catch?
And especially in a community
where the GPL and open source
was so much part
of the ethos, we
wondered, are people
going to accept us?
I want to tackle these questions
one by one a little bit
out of order.
The first one being, are R
users ready to write web apps?
And what we learned was this.
R users are not
afraid to learn.
I mean, think of who
you need to be to even
be considering learning Shiny.
OK you learn statistics.
You know about visualization.
You learned to code.
You know git.
You probably know the
grammar of graphics.
Yeah I think they can sit
through a few tutorials
and read some reference
documentation.
R users were not afraid and
continue to not be afraid.
And R users were and are
incredibly motivated by what
Shiny offers them.
We did not have to sell
very hard for people
to realize Shiny was not just
one more tool in their toolbox,
but it was a force
multiplier for everything
that they can
already do in R,
because it meant those
existing skills could
be exposed to a broader audience
than they could otherwise
accomplish.
And Shiny produced "mic
drop" moments for R users
I'm going to go out a
little bit on a limb
here and tell me if
this sounds familiar.
I heard multiple
stories of people
going into a conference
room with their Shiny app
and leaving jaws on the floor.
I'm going to go out on a limb.
Can I see a show of hands?
Anyone had this experience
written a Shiny app that.
Yeah, see, I'm not making it up.
And that's a huge
motivator for people.
And something about Shiny feels
within reach to R users,
even though there
are a lot of concepts
that you need to learn.
Somehow it feels like
we wrote this for you.
We wrote this expecting you
to come along and learn it.
And that felt different
than TypeScript and React
and these other web
technologies where
it felt like this was
really for somebody else
and you would have to become
somebody else to learn
this set of skills.
And these things might
almost seem obvious by now,
but it wasn't back then.
And in 2012 to 2015 there
was a Cambrian explosion
of reactive frameworks in
all different languages
and most of them are forgotten.
Because most of them
didn't find a user base
that was motivated by
what they had to offer
or they couldn't make it
past the learning curve.
So I just want to be clear.
I don't take this for granted.
It's amazing.
It's amazing that things
worked out this way.
So the question we
had going into this
is are R users ready
to write web apps?
And the conclusion
that I've come to
is that R has the best
audience for Shiny.
It's perfect.
The next question.
Would the R community respond?
And instead of telling
you, let me just show you.
This is just a list
off the top of my head
the other day of some of
the many amazing packages
that people have released
that are built on top of Shiny
and enhance the capabilities
of Shiny in some way.
And I know that a lot
of you in this audience
are using these
packages, and the authors
of some of these packages are
here in the audience as well.
Maintaining an open source
package that people actually
use is not an easy feat.
And a lot of people put a lot
of time into the packages,
not only on this list,
but on all the ones
that I don't have
room to list here.
And again, I don't
take that lightly.
That is a huge
vote of confidence
in the work that we're doing
and the foundation that we've
built. So I am so grateful
to all these people.
And there's a GitHub
user called nanxstats
that has a document
called Awesome Shiny
Extensions on GitHub.
And this is a list
of just a whole bunch
of packages written in R
that extend or enhance Shiny
in some way.
There's a few.
Again, it's humbling to see
how much time and energy
people have invested in
trying to make Shiny better.
And as Hadley said,
writing books ain't easy.
I'm sorry, this is
unscripted, but I
believe the first advice you
gave me about book writing
was I asked, how does it
work with getting a publisher
or whatever?
And he said, step
one, write a book.
Step two, get it published.
There's no step three.
Yeah, not great advice.
So I am astounded that there
are I mean, not just three,
but there there are
several more complete books
that people have written
about Shiny and again,
knowing how hard it is
to put together a book,
I'm in awe that there are people
who are doing this for Shiny.
And I don't think we can really
talk about the Shiny community
without mentioning Eric Nantz.
Is Eric Nantz around
here somewhere?
Oh, there he is.
Yeah Eric Nantz might be the
biggest cheerleader for Shiny
inside or outside of RStudio.
And among the many
contributions,
contributions that
Eric has made is
he currently has this Shiny
developer series going.
It is, what, 30 plus
episodes and counting
of really interesting
and deep conversations
with very interesting
and deep people
around the Shiny community.
So I definitely encourage
you to check that out.
And there are so many other
ways people contribute
that are not necessarily
in those categories.
Every GitHub issue or PR,
it takes time and energy
to put together reprexes,
to put together patches.
And I appreciate
every single one.
Every year, we hold
a Shiny contest
and I'm blown away by the
amount of care people put
into crafting these submissions.
It clearly means
a lot to people.
Blog posts, conference
talks, workshops.
There's so much content that
people put together about Shiny
and it is not easy.
There are entire tutorials
that were created
by people in the community.
Zev Ross here in the front
row created a tutorial
talking about how to
use Shiny from scratch
with a bent toward ggplot.
And that got a lot of people
into Shiny in the beginning.
Appsilon, are the
Appsilon guys here?
The Appsilon folks.
Yep they did a Shiny conference.
Didn't see that coming.
So, I'm sorry.
You know, it's been 10 years.
Please, can you
just give me this?
I'm so grateful to
all these people
and all the different kinds
of contributions they've made.
And because I have the
attention of this whole room,
and a lot of the people in
the community are in this room.
Can we just take a
second and all say
thank you to all these people?
So, if the question was, will
the R community respond?
I can't even, I can't
even put into words how
the community has responded.
And finally, can we
even build it in R?
In 2012, you might have
heard things like, R is a DSL.
A domain specific language.
The alternative to R isn't
Python or C#, it's SAS.
You never use R for,
you know, a web server.
These are real quotes
from a real talk
that was given by John D. Cook,
at GOTO 2012. And this is
not to pick on John D. Cook.
These were totally reasonable
statements at the time.
And what we found
was not just that it
was going to be possible
to do this in R
but it was bizarrely
good as a host language,
for Shiny, bizarrely good.
And I feel like that's sort
of an extraordinary claim.
So I will provide some evidence.
It's going to get a
little bit geeky, so just
be ready for the shift in tone.
A lot of languages have
positional and named arguments.
Programming languages.
A positional arg like you
see here is like x, right?
There's no name.
You just put it with the
right number of commas
and it gets matched up.
And then you have
named arguments
where you specify exactly
what parameter you're passing.
Height equals twenty in this case.
And tons of languages,
tons of languages have both
positional and named arguments.
But what almost
none of them have.
None that are in current
use that I could find.
R allows the named arguments
to be passed first.
Super random weird quirk.
Nobody does this.
This is not considered
a best practice.
Python doesn't do it.
Ruby doesn't do it.
C# doesn't do it.
None of these languages
that have both named
and positional args let
you put them in this order.
And by the way, in R you can
put it in whatever order
you can mix them.
It's R, you know.
And this matters for Shiny.
It matters for
Shiny because a lot
of what the UI
layer of Shiny does
is express HTML and think
about how you express HTML.
If you're familiar with HTML.
If not, hopefully you'll
be able to follow along.
An HTML tag really lets
you express three things.
The tag itself.
In this case, on
the outside, we have
a UL tag for an unordered list.
Secondly, the attributes for
that tag describing well,
attributes about the tag.
In this case, it's saying
that this unordered list is
for the purpose of navigation.
Third and last,
you have children.
What are the things that are
contained inside of this tag?
But this order is
the right order.
This is the way we
think about it, right?
What am I making a UL?
What are the attributes of that?
Ul it's an.
And then what's inside
the UL? Children.
So if this is the
structure we're aiming at,
how closely can we
match that in R?
Pretty close, as it turns out.
Pretty close.
It almost looks like we've just
taken away some angle brackets
and added some parentheses
and some commas.
Sorry about the commas.
It's the same order.
UL first.
Attribute second.
Children third.
And it's only
because we're allowed
to put the named
arguments that we're
using for attributes first.
So just to take a
language at random.
Let's talk about Python.
Python has named arguments,
but they have to go last.
So we end up with tag first.
Attributes at the bottom.
And then all the children.
And that is a problem because
it adds all this space that you
have to look past in order
to find out what kind of UL,
you're creating.
And this example
is just 12 lines,
but you can imagine if this
is a production dashboard,
it might be screen fulls
that you have to traverse.
So I don't want
to put up
the weakest straw man possible.
So let's steel man
it a little bit.
Right so.
Here is one option that
you could use in Python
to improve the situation.
You could get rid
of named arguments
altogether and
express everything
with positional arguments.
And you could do that.
You could put a dictionary
at the top similar to a named
list, I guess.
And this would work.
It adds some curly braces.
It adds some quotation marks.
So it's not perfect,
but it certainly works.
I'm not to argue
it doesn't work.
I would call this maybe 85% as
good as what you can do in R.
The other way you
go in Python is
to go all named arguments
so you don't pass children
as unnamed arguments.
Instead you make a named
argument called children
and give it a list.
Again, the details
here aren't important.
The point is that while
the point is it's worse,
I guess, that's the point.
And this one to me is
worse than the previous one
because it actually pushes
the code off the page.
We've added a line, a vertical
line and a level of indentation
for each level of
children at this point.
OK and also switching
from UI to reactivity.
Non-standard evaluation
ended up being weirdly,
bizarrely good for
reactive programming,
not something that
we had anticipated.
This is what my sort of
if I could wave a magic
wand and have a language
to express reactivity in,
it might look
something like this,
I want a language keyword
for the word reactive.
That's an important concept.
I want to attach a code
block to that keyword.
And then reading something
out of a reactive expression
like read_data, say I
want a star operator.
Sort of like referencing
a pointer and see.
So this is kind of what,
you know, if I got my wish,
this is what a perfect language
for reactivity would look like.
And let's see what we have
in R. It's pretty close.
In Python, we have to
go a different way.
Python does not have
non-standard evaluation,
so you can't pass a bare
block of code to a function
and expect it to be anything
but a value by the time
the function gets at it.
Instead, in Python, you have
to write a function, a named
function, and then you have
to apply reactivity to it.
Now, again, I don't want to
leave you with a straw man.
So here's the steel man.
Python has a few tricks
of its own up its sleeve,
and this is called a decorator.
And you know what?
This is not bad.
I'll say this is maybe,
like, 90% as good as R.
I still don't love that
it's a function.
It feels like you
made a function
and then you made it reactive.
And I really prefer
how it looks in R
where what sort of feels like
you've constructed a reactive.
But I'm not going to argue that
this doesn't work and doesn't
have appeal to people who
come from this tradition.
OK so can we even
build it in R?
R is the best
language for Shiny.
I will die on this hill.
R is the best
language for Shiny.
So those three big
questions were answered.
Can we even build
it in R?
R is the best language for
Shiny.
Are R users ready to write web apps? R has
the best audience for Shiny.
And will the R community respond?
To almost an absurd degree, you have responded.
So, yes.
Shiny has been a success.
So I hope that
I've convinced you,
or at least I've convinced
you that I am convinced that R
is the best language for Shiny.
But you know what
they say about Python?
Python is the second best
language for anything.
language for anything,
and that is not an insult.
That is a compliment.
That quote was popularized by
Dan Callahan at Python 2018
during a keynote.
He said, Python is the second
best language for anything,
and that is an
amazing aspiration
because it means that whatever
domain you're operating in,
whatever weird new technique in
computing you're interested in,
there's a pretty good chance
that you can stitch something
together in Python,
and it might not
be the very best version
or the very best expression
of that idea, but it
will be available to you
without going somewhere else.
And there is undoubtedly
power in that.
So introducing Shiny for Python.
Like 45% of you
are real excited.
Here is an app running
in Shiny for Python.
This is sort of our July 31,
2012 moment for Shiny for R.
That's about where we are
today with Shiny for Python.
I don't expect you to be
able to read this code,
but if you could,
And, you know, Shiny
for R and, you know,
a little bit of Python, this is
going to look pretty familiar.
There are a lot of concepts that
carry through between the two,
even though we are dealing
with two separate languages.
And the server side is
filled with the same kind
of reactive concepts that you're
used to from Shiny for R.
And before we go further, I have
to warn you, this is in alpha,
and it's especially
alpha because we
did all this work in secret.
and we're not used
to doing that.
None of us really like it.
We're really happy to not
have to do it after today.
So we are not ready
to call something
out of alpha until the community
has had a chance to bang on it.
And we still reserve the
right to change the API.
So I want to I'm going
to give you that Warning.
Our design philosophy
for Shiny for Python
was that it's very similar
conceptually to Shiny for R
and that wasn't necessarily
a first principle that we
started with.
We were open to changing our
ideas as we move from R to Python
and vice versa.
But I think what we found
was a lot of the trade offs
that we had made in R
were pretty universal
and they felt pretty
good in Python,
but it's not a slavishly
literal import from R.
We don't want Shiny for
Python to feel like it
was written by R users.
We want it to feel
idiomatically like Python.
So to give an example of what
I mean when I say, you know,
Python is the second best
language for anything.
I tapped our resident
astrophysicist, Dr. Julia Silge
not a joke.
And I asked her, you
know, I hear Python maybe
is big in astronomy,
is there something we could
do with a Shiny app for that?
And she had this idea for
an air mass calculator.
And long story
short, this lets you
provide a list of
astronomical objects
you're interested in
observing on a certain day
and from a certain
location on Earth.
And this calculator will
tell you what times of night
are optimal for viewing
that object, including,
(I'm not an astronomer)
How much air lies
along your line
of sight between you and
the object you're viewing?
Because depending on its
angle from the horizon,
you're going through a
different amount of atmosphere.
So that's what this air mass
calculator is showing you.
Super easy to do
because of AstroPy
and super easy to turn into
this app because of Shiny.
So Shiny for Python again
alpha it is available now.
If you go to shiny.rstudio.com/py, you'll
find lots of documentation.
There are examples, there's
articles, there's API docs.
And I want to talk a little
bit about editor support.
We expect that most
people are probably
going to be writing
these things in VS Code
and we've written an
extension for authoring
Shiny for Python and VS Code.
If you use something else
like PyCharm or Jupyter lab,
that should work too.
We're a pretty standard Python
web framework in that respect.
RStudio IDE is going to get
basic support for Shiny for
Python apps in the next release.
That'll be mostly in the
form of a run app button.
And if you are using RStudio
Workbench to have RStudio
on the server, then the VS
Code and Jupyter lab versions
that are run on RStudio
Workbench work great
if you have the current release
of
RStudio Workbench, Spotted Wakerobin.
Now because Shiny
for Python is Shiny,
we have to talk about
deployment options.
And I'm so pleased.
I'm so pleased to tell
you, this is working today
on Shinyapps.io you can deploy
Shiny for Python apps today.
RStudio Connect already
supports Shiny for Python
and it's current version,
the one that came out
earlier this month.
It's just not documented.
At our request.
And rsconnect-python
is the CLI tool you
use to deploy to those servers.
And as of today,
assuming everything
went well, I'm getting the nod.
Yes, this is available
now in rsconnect-python.
And of course, as JJ
said this morning,
we never want to lock up your
work and proprietary solutions.
So we do always have
an open source option available,
Oh... It'll be fully released when
I get back to my hotel room.
There was one more button I needed to hit.
Listen, guys, it's a long talk,
and I was very nervous.
Instructions for all
of this is they're
all available on the
Shiny for Python site
under the deploy tab.
There is one more deployment
option for Shiny for Python.
You can deploy it to
a static web server.
...wait, what?
And I'm sorry, I'm going to have
to leave you with that teaser,
because Winston Chang
is going to talk about
this tomorrow at 11:30 AM.
Running Shiny without a server.
I've got to say,
this is, I mean, this
is a magic trick of our own.
When Winston suggested
this technique,
I actually told
him not to do it.
I said you are
wasting your time,
and he proved me
wrong within 48 hours.
So it should be a
talk to remember.
I do have to give
a little caveats,
some restrictions apply,
not all apps will be eligible,
serious side effects may occur,
must be 18 years or older.
You don't need to be
18 years or older.
But I'm not joking
about the other ones.
There are caveats.
This is not going to be
a universal model for how
we deploy Shiny for
Python, but the fact
that this is even
possible is incredible.
And I think for definitely
some of you in this room,
it's going to be a
powerful way to deploy
Shiny for Python apps.
Now I want to make it clear
that the future of Shiny
is not Python.
The future of Shiny
is R and Python.
And I don't want you to think
that we only have goodies for
the Python community today.
Again, a lot of this
work was done in secret,
so we have to consider it alpha.
But man, the things
you might have
known that Shiny for
Python was coming.
I don't think that this
next one is coming.
A visual editor for Shiny UI.
Now, some of you that have
known me for a long time
might be a little bit surprised.
I mean, this has been
suggested many times,
and I have shot it down
sometimes in a principled tone.
So Nick Strayer is
going to talk about why
we think that this is the right
time for us to do something
like this and how we
avoided the pitfalls that I
was so worried about when
it came to visual editors.
Greg Swinehart is
a developer who
has worked with and for RStudio
for gosh like 10 years now.
And recently Greg
joined the Shiny team
to help us help you make better
designed, better looking apps.
So it's early
stages, but Greg is
going to talk about both some
of his own design principles
that come to mind as
he looks at Shiny apps
and how they can be better.
And also some of the
components that we're
creating that will
help make it easier
for you to fall into
a pit of success
when it comes to your designs.
And finally, Barrett
Schloerke is going
to be talking about
Shinytest2.
This is not secret.
This is up on cran
and Shinytest2
is a fundamental part of
the Shiny stack for anybody
who cares about robustness and
keeping their apps bug-free.
It's really difficult work,
and it takes a lot of patience
and it's not
particularly glamorous.
And I think Barrett Schloerke, I
can't think of a better person
to tackle these kinds
of hard problems.
I'm sorry.
I can't resist this.
Can anyone dead lift more
than 503 pounds in this room?
And Barret Schloerke is also
the strongest person
at rstudio::conf.
He's also a new dad, but
there's lots of new dads.
That's 503 pounds.
That's ridiculous.
This is team Shiny.
This is the hardest- I knew
this going to be the
hardest part of my talk.
It's my favorite slide and
it was the hardest thing
to come up with
anything to say.
I'm so grateful to this team.
I'm so grateful for the work
that we've done together
over the last year.
All right.
Thank you very much.
If you want to learn more
about Shiny for Python,
you can go to this link
or use the QR code.
And don't forget these talks
tomorrow by Shiny team members.
Thank you so much for
10 great years of Shiny.
Thanks, Joe.
Thanks, everyone.
Well, while we wait for
our questions on the slido,
I had one more comment for
Joe, because during this talk
I remembered I think it
was in 2012 like Joe,
it must have been
like at UseR or JSM.
Like Joe was telling
me about this idea
he had to do a web app, a web
application framework in R
and I was like, in my head.
Yeah Joe that's
JUST what R needs...
A "web development framework."
So another case where
I was very, very wrong.
So first question for you, Joe.
How did you come up
with the name Shiny?
Yes so the name Shiny comes
from a show called Firefly.
A few months before
Shiny became a thing,
I was laying sick in bed and
I watched the whole series
Firefly for the first time,
and they used the word shiny
to mean good.
They'll say, "yeah,
I'm feeling shiny."
"Yeah, this job is
going really shiny."
And I just thought
like, oh, that's... I
liked how they just sort of
slipped that in all casual.
And I thought that'd be a cool
name for a project someday.
The day that I was
creating the GitHub repo.
For the first commit of what
was to become Shiny on GitHub.
There's a little name
suggester, right?
It says "Having trouble
thinking of a name?
It's blah, blah, blah."
And it's three segments.
I don't remember
the first segment,
but it was like it maybe it was
something like ninja, octo cat,
Shiny, and I was like, all
right, that's a sign from God.
It's Shiny.
That's what it's going to be.
I know I've asked you
this question myself,
what do you think of
people calling Shiny, R Shiny?
Yeah, I think maybe Dean Attali
popularized this and just felt
like it hit's more
clear, and he really was
successful in popularizing it.
And I think for people
in internal to RStudio,
they'd frequently asked me, hey,
is it R Shiny or is it Shiny?
And I said, it's Shiny.
It's not R Shiny,
it's just Shiny.
And so I think all of us sort
of developed a little bit
of an aversion to R Shiny.
But now that there's
Shiny for Python,
it's going to be hard
not to call it R Shiny.
So I've made my peace with it.
So what about... Obviously other
similar frameworks like Dash
and Streamlit exist...
Why Shiny for Python?
Yeah, totally.
It's a valid question.
And it's a really
interesting question
we didn't have to face
with Shiny for R.
I think that there, as these
frameworks were coming out,
we looked at them,
each one of them,
and we were curious, not
even from a competitive point
of view, but just
out of curiosity,
what were their approaches?
What trade offs had they chosen?
And it turned out that
despite the proliferation
of these kinds of web frameworks
and Python, all of the trade
offs that they
chose were actually
quite different than what
we were doing with Shiny.
And I think the kinds of
apps that I see people build,
people in this
room, a lot of them
would actually be difficult
to build given the trade offs
inherent in those other.
You know, this is not
a Python conference.
It's not Posit Con.
It's rstudio::conf.
So I don't want to
belabor it, but I
do want to say that there
are real differences.
We think that there's room for
something new in the Python
world.
Somewhat related.
What about py script?
Oh, the new thing
that Peter Wang presented.
Yes so py script is a really
interesting piece of technology
that sort of goes the other way.
It lets you take an HTML page
that might have Javascript,
might have whatever in it,
and it lets you embed Python.
Snippets of code into
your JavaScript apps.
Basically, I think they
want to replace JavaScript
as the language of directly
manipulating web apps.
So that replaces one
part of the stack.
It replaces the
language JavaScript
with the language Python.
So I think that's an
interesting endeavor
and certainly very impressive
technically and quite different
than I think what
we're trying to do,
which is to go from Python
and sort of relieve you
from having to have to think
about the entire stack.
So the orchestration of how
data moves back and forth
between the server
and the client.
There's just a lot of things
that are part of our stack
that py script is just
out of scope.
Now you mentioned
that we might be
able to run
Shiny for Python
without of server.
What about Shiny for R?
We sure hope.
We sure hope so.
The thing is that right now
the technology that this.
Is it OK if I say the word?
This approach that we're taking
for running in the browser,
it's called Wasm.
And Python is the second
best language for Wasm.
Yeah those guys every time.
Yeah they're the second
best language for Wasm.
Yeah rust is
probably number one.
So the question really is
about is R going to have Wasm?
and the answer is.
Why don't you answer that?
Yes so that is something that
we're going to be working on.
You might want to ask
George Stagg, who's
recently joined RStudio, is giving a lightning
talk about this.
So we are actively
working to bring Wasm for R
so you can
take any application
and compile it to
Javascript, basically.
I feel like we just did a really
bad version of, like, Winston's
and George's talk.
Sorry, you should,
you should,
you should check them out.
It's going to be very exciting.
OK, I've got a high
stress question for you,
but I'm going to follow it up
with a low stress question.
So when will the
book that covers
all of these
exciting new features
be out Joe? Whenever
Hadley needs a new bike?
Would it be possible to
use both R and Python
within a single app?
Could you use both R and
Python in a single app?
I mean, I suppose you could
do something with reticulate.
We know you can because
people do use reticulate
with Shiny for R and I'm sure
the reverse works as well.
But yeah,
definitely not something
that we have thought a lot about
in building Shiny for Python.
How about other packages
in the kind of Shiny
ecosystem like Shinytest2 and HTML tools?
Are you going to bring
those to Python as well?
Yeah, I sure hope so.
Again, this is the 2012
moment of Shiny for Python.
Anything is possible.
Are those three
big questions going
to be answered the same way
in the Python community?
Nobody knows.
So I think it would
probably be premature
for me to stand here and say
that all these things are
going to appear.
But it is certainly
our intention
if we're successful in the
fullness of time, for Shiny
for Python to be a mature and
complete stack in the same way
that Shiny for R is.
So sort of following
up on that, is the plan
to have the features
developed at the same pace
for both R and Python
in the future?
Oh will the feature be
developed at the same pace?
Certainly for features where
Python is catching up to R
naturally it's going to go much
faster in Python than it ever
did in R because we're doing
everything for a second time.
It is just much easier when
you have solved a problem once.
In terms of new features,
we haven't really
talked about this,
but I wouldn't
want to commit to any kind
of artificial, artificially
enforced parity.
I mean, I think part of
the point of what we're
trying to do here
is to not focus
on keeping these things equal.
We want them to both
be as good as they
can be for their
respective communities.
And we might make a
different set of trade offs
if we expected that people
were going to switch
back and forth every day.
But, no doubt there will be
some people who do that.
I mean, maybe even people
in this room who do that.
But I think we really
want to optimize
for if you're spending a lot
of time in Shiny for R,
it feels good as an R user.
And if you spend a lot of
time in Shiny for Python,
it feels good as a Python user.
So we are going to try to make
each of those frameworks as
good as they can be.
So we'll finish up with a
potentially dangerous question.
And bear in mind we only
have three minutes left,
so someone would like
to know, don't go
into too much technical detail.
What sort of bike
did you build me?
I know nothing about the
bike, except it's awesome.
So this is definitely
a Joe question.
It is an All-City Space Horse.
It's a steel, light touring
bike and I blinged it out.
It was pretty spectacular.
Did you show a picture
I couldn't see?
No, I didn't show a picture.
But I can I'll tweet
a I'll tweet a picture
so people can appreciate it.
Yeah, I'll tweet the picture.
So thank you, Joe.
Thank you all.
And enjoy the rest
of the conference.
Thank you.